[Musik]
morgen ab 7 uhr ist es soweit da wird
das airpower gelände für sie geöffnet
und das natürlich bei freiem eintritt
heute treffen noch die letzten fünf
staffeln in zeltweg ein das wetter hält
und ist besser als erwartet die erste
staffel sie heute hier am fliegerhorst
hinterstoisser landet kommt auf der
schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum ein besonderes programm
die baut swiss war ja der 56 mai und für
dieses jubiläum haben wir ein spezielles
programm zusammengestellt das vielleicht
das ein oder andere geheimnis verraten
was ist das hingegen wird wir haben 23
in den programmen immer noch nicht
die leute nicht so weit wie möglich
kommen
wenn das wetter so bleibt es ist optimal
aber wir müssen es sein dass sie nicht
mehr die luft gehen können
die wolkenuntergrenze muss mindestens
300 meter überbot und sein und die sicht
mindestens 5 km und dann können wir
fliegen und wir sind es gewohnt aus der
schweiz in den bergen zu fliegen ich
denke ich bin optimistisch dass wir auch
dieses wochenende hier in österreich
fliegen werden herzlich willkommen in
zeltweg vielen dank vielen herzlichen
dank wir freuen uns
[Musik]
unterwegs das ist einer der letzten
fliegenden richtig ja das ist einer von
zweien wir haben einen zweisitzer vor
drei jahren hier gehabt und heuer ist es
dieser tragen sind erstmals 1955
geflogen dieser hier wurde 1969 gebaut
50-jähriges jubiläum also dürfte erst
über sie wissen dass diese flieger in
österreich viele jahre im dienst waren
sie sind hier etwas ganz besonderes nein
das glaube ich nicht vor einigen jahren
habe ich hier mit anderen piloten
trainiert aber das ist es dann auch
schon
[Musik]
wie war ihr trainingsflug sehr gut wir
sind sehr froh wieder hier zu sein in
zeltweg das letzte mal waren wir vor
sechs jahren hier zwischen den bergen
zwei tage sonne und wir hoffen den
leuten gefällt unser programm
wir haben es jedenfalls genoss ist die
airpower 2009 10 eine spezielle wir
waren jetzt eine lange zeit nicht hier
die airpower ist ein highlight in der
saison in europa wir sind sehr froh hier
eingeladen zu sein und wir freuen uns
immer wieder unsere freunde und kollegen
zu treffen
wir werden in österreich immer sehr
herzlich von den luftstreitkräften
willkommen geheißen
wir sind einfach
[Musik]